[Música]
búsqueda contrarreloj en el Océano
Atlántico Estados Unidos y Canadá
intentan encontrar un submarino
turístico que se dirigía a las ruinas
del Titanic la nave desapareció este
domingo y se quedaría sin oxígeno el
miércoles
nuevo tiroteo en Brasil la policía
detuvo a un joven de 21 años como
presunto autor del ataque a una escuela
en el Estado de Paraná que causó la
muerte de una estudiante e hirió a otro
de gravedad Tenemos reporte desde Brasil
hace un año Gustavo Petro hizo historia
al ser elegido el primer presidente de
izquierdas de Colombia y lo hizo
acompañado de la vicepresidenta Francia
Márquez el gobierno avanza entre
reformas bloqueadas en el parlamento
escándalos y la difícil Promesa de la
paz total
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano
empezamos en las aguas del Océano
Atlántico donde a esta hora Estados
Unidos y Canadá protagonizan una carrera
contra el tiempo para encontrar el
submarino turístico titán desaparecido
el domingo mientras se dirigía a las
ruinas del Titanic la nave de la
compañía privada oceangate llevaría
cinco pasajeros y dispone de oxígeno
hasta el miércoles Alba Santana tiene
los detalles
iba en camino hacia los restos del
Titanic cuando el sumergible titán de
Ocean Gates expeditions desapareció y
con él las cinco personas a bordo el
piloto y cuatro pasajeros que pagaron
250.000 dólares por persona para
acercarse al pedazo de historia que
representa el Titanic el sumergible una
nave similar a un submarino pero más
pequeña y con menos potencia partió
desde Saint Jones en la mañana del
domingo y emprendió un viaje de 640
kilómetros hacia el fondo del océano
antes de perderse
es una zona muy remota y es un reto
llevar a cabo una búsqueda en una zona
tan remota
pero estamos desplegando todos los
medios disponibles para asegurarnos de
que podemos localizar la embarcación y
rescatar a las personas a bordo
entre los miembros de la tripulación
Además del capitán se encuentra el
multimillonario británico James jarding
en estos momentos las principales
hipótesis de lo sucedido son dos que el
sumergible haya perdido la comunicación
pero siga en funcionamiento o que haya
tenido un accidente según los expertos
las personas a bordo cuentan con un
Rango de 70 a 90 horas restantes de
oxígeno
Sí es muy preocupante tendrá algo de
aire de reserva en botellas comprimidas
y cosas por el estilo pero solo durará
un tiempo determinado para muchos es
inevitable hacer comparaciones entre la
suerte que corrió el famoso Titanic a
cuando se hundió en 1912 y la del
submarino aunque los expertos aseguran a
una y esperanzas y posibilidades reales
de encontrarlos a con vida
este lunes el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken concluyó
su esperada visita china donde se reunió
con el presidente
la cuestión de Taiwán y la Guerra de
Ucrania fueron algunos de los temas
principales en la agenda pero el
fentanilo un opioide que causa decenas
de miles de muertes al año en Estados
Unidos y cuyos precursores químicos se
fabrican en China también fue motivo de
discusión
el fentanilo una droga que está matando
a estadounidenses a un ritmo alarmante
fue uno de los temas de la agenda de
Anthony blinken durante su visita a
China utilizado originalmente como
potente analgésico se ha convertido en
una amenaza para la salud pública en
Estados Unidos y en otro punto de
discordia entre Beijing y Washington el
opioides sintético es el responsable de
un tercio de la sobredosis en Estados
Unidos y Washington dice que China tiene
parte de culpa
creemos que el movimiento de precursores
químicos para el fentanilo desde china a
otros países es una cuestión importante
que tenemos que abordar y sobre la que
queremos que tomen medidas
Estados Unidos ha alegado que china ha
suministrado los productos químicos
necesarios para fabricar a fentanilo a
los carteles mexicanos que luego
trafican con la droga en Estados Unidos
china sin embargo dijo que los
precursores químicos eran ingredientes
ordinarios que se pueden conseguir
ilegalmente según Beijing Estados Unidos
debería esforzarse más por controlar
importaciones
sin ningún fundamento y basándose en
Casos individuales de paquetes postales
procedentes de China los que se ha
detectado fentanilo Estados Unidos
afirma que las sustancias de fentanilo
proceden principalmente de China estas
afirmaciones carecen de fundamento y
están engañando al público
en diciembre de 2022 los legisladores
estadounidenses aprobaron la ley de
resultados del fentanilo según un
congresista demócrata está exige que el
departamento de estado colabore con las
fuerzas de seguridad chinas mexicanas y
de otros países para trabajar en la
detección de drogas sintéticas la semana
pasada Washington y Beijing habrían
reanudado las conversaciones sobre el
control de drogas por primera vez en
meses un tímido intento de cooperación
entre los dos rivales
vamos ahora Brasil porque un nuevo
ataque en una escuela dejó una
estudiante muerta y a otro herido de
gravedad los hechos ocurrieron en el
municipio de cambe esto es en el Estado
de Paraná al sur del país según las
autoridades el autor es un ex alumno de
21 años que ya fue detenido pero todavía
se desconoce el motivo del crimen se
trata del quinto ataque en una escuela
de Brasil en lo que va del año y
previamente nuestra corresponsal Valeria
sacone nos contó a que responde este
aumento de la violencia Armada en el
país
los principales expertos de Brasil
apuntan a dos causas para explicar la
escalada de la violencia en las escuelas
de Brasil por un lado la proliferación
de armas durante el mandato de Jair
bolsonaro cuando más de un millón de
armas llegaron a manos de coleccionistas
cazadores y tiradores deportivos gracias
a las nuevas leyes el gobierno de Lula
lanzado una campaña para registrar de
nuevo todas las armas tener un control y
evitar que esas armas estén en manos de
personas peligrosas o que circulen de
forma ilegal Pero hay otra causa sería
el efecto emulación potenciado gracias a
las redes sociales le hemos visto en
este caso del Paraná con el cuaderno que
llevaba el asesino por esta razón los
principales medios de comunicación de
Brasil han alcanzado un acuerdo para no
revelar la identidad de los autores de
esas masajes escolares y así reducir su
fama y por otra parte el congreso de los
diputados está discutiendo un proyecto
de ley que quiere obligar a las grandes
plataformas a realizar una verdadera
moderación de los contenidos violentos
en las redes sociales y también de la
publicidad asociada a la violencia por
un lado las grandes plataformas como
Telegram o Google están haciendo campaña
contra el gobierno de Lula Por otra
parte los bolsonaristas y en general los
liberales le acusan de querer implantar
una censura pero los principales
expertos en tecnología en sociología
dicen que si Brasil consigue aprobar
esta ley estaría en la vanguardia
mundial en lo que es moderación y
control de los contenidos violentos en
internet
hace exactamente un año Gustavo Petro y
Francia Márquez fueron elegidos como
primer presidente y primera
vicepresidenta de izquierdas de la
historia de Colombia asumieron El Cargo
en agosto y desde entonces el trabajo
del ejecutivo ha estado marcado por el
proyecto de la paz total el intento por
aprobar ambiciosas y polémicas reformas
así como por la remodelaciones súbitas
de gabinete previamente hablamos con el
politólogo y analista internacional
Manuel Alejandro rairán sobre cómo Petro
puede lograr el cambio que prometió
Bueno yo creo que tiene que tener varias
estrategias la primera de ellas es que
tiene que mejorar sus estrategias de
comunicación Creo yo que no ha sido
acertado en la manera como se ha
expresado el presidente y la
vicepresidente por sus redes sociales
entonces creo que tiene que ser más
asertivos y estrativos en ese aspecto lo
segundo creo que tiene que crear una
estrategia que movilice mucho más el
gabinete con el congreso para poder dar
digamos abierta discusión a la reformas
y en el tercer caso en el sentido de las
calles yo digamos quiero Que obviamente
el presidente quiere reforzar su capital
político electoral que fue el que lo
llevó a las calles Si eso desconocer que
el otro 49% de la población pues no lo
apoyó a él vale Creo yo que en relación
con eso él tiene el derecho de seguir
manteniendo su apoyo de su de su
electorado Pero tiene que tener cuidado
no caer en tratar de suplantar el estado
de opinión con el estado de derecho creo
que aquí el presidente tiene que tener
claro que el estado de derecho tiene que
primar por encima del del estado de
opinión y de las calles y que por el
contrario tiene que seguir abriendo
Estos espacios de discusión y debate no
solamente en el congreso no solamente
con Los jefes políticos de los partidos
sino creo que también tendría que abrir
más espacios políticos para escuchar las
diferentes voces de la sociedad
colombiana
hasta aquí las noticias
[Música]